first let's just unpack the fact that
you've just dropped
probably the most important lesson in
life
which is that your body
has intelligent design and it is
constantly sending you signals
and when something shrinks you depletes
you makes you feel like you're hiding
that is a
hugely important signal to pay attention
to and one of the simple secrets in life
is
spend more time with people
and doing experiences that expand you or
energize you and you also said something
important it has nothing to do with
whether or not something is easy
or something is difficult and has
everything to do
with the kind of energy that you feel
when you're either in that experience or
you are with
those people that are meant for you and
so that's number one
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast today i have mel robbins and i
have been listening to mel robbins speak
for so long she's so clear so articulate
so passionate and and has really lived
it she's a former attorney uh she's a
new york times bestselling author her
most recent book is called the high five
habit so of course we talked about the
high five and power of the high five and
there's so much science behind it
there's been so many studies between
everything from sports teams to kids to
classrooms you name it there's been so
many different examples of the power of
the high five but in general we just
talked so much about you know getting to
see ourselves in our in our life being
able to see ourselves in our patterns
being able to see ourselves in our
relationships and our work and
ultimately choosing us and how we treat
ourselves and
what we can do to
wake up and um really it ultimately ends
up leading to just more happiness more
joy
and more contentment in this life which
is something i think we're all looking
for more of
but mel comes from a place where she's
lived it she lived it she was broken
about a million dollars in debt only
like six years ago and she pulled
herself out and it's just super
inspiring
uh which is why she's able to speak
about it with such conviction and such
knowledge so enjoy the show you've been
working
um today
i'm good i um completely
overdid it and um
you know kind of [ __ ] myself over
honestly from a health perspective
because i
in
like 10 weeks did 70 plus podcast
interviews crisscross the country three
keynotes went to europe for a book like
i just over oh i saw that yeah
and so my body shut down and said we're
done here and it was right in the middle
of an audible production which was not
great because i hate letting people you
know you know i mean you you have
uh played at the highest levels in
everything that you've done and when i'm
sick it's one thing but when i get sick
and worn down and it actually impacts
other people's
kind of schedules and stuff that really
bums me out but i'm good now i'm really
good now how are you that's an admirable
trait though a lot of you know i don't
think everyone thinks like that and
there's a certain point especially with
your level of success where people can
feel like they're
they're the important one and in charge
and who cares about everybody else and
so
i think that's a really grounded and
like solid perspective to have
oh well thank you thank you yeah um
i mean i get it you're right i mean i'm
i'm good i feel like i you know when i
retired i'm like i want to do less but i
also got to do more of what i wanted so
you know it keeps you in an energized
space i learned towards the end of my
career that the things that drained me
weren't for me and the things that gave
me energy were definitely in alignment
and it didn't even mean that the
workload was the same it could have been
like
minuscule amounts of things that i
didn't want to do that would be like
exponentially draining and then on the
other side it could be something that
was a high volume amount of work
work um but it energized me and left me
feeling almost high from it and you're
you know you start to realize how
important the things when things are in
alignment and i think that you know that
was a lesson i learned but um but i'm
good now i'm good but also you know as
you're talking about this and you know
you're obviously doing things you're
passionate about you're talking about i
mean like i've listened to you for so
long and you know you're your speaking
is so articulate and to the point and i
love that you swear and who cares about
anyone who complains about that i love
it and it's like a way to get across the
message um and you're so clear um
but you know there's also a season for
things so you know you write a book and
you're passionate about the message but
it it it's like it doesn't mean that
there aren't some other things that go
along with it and it's like you know
what are your thoughts about like you
know some it's just a season for stuff
do you know what i mean by that
well
yeah okay so first let's just unpack the
fact that you've just dropped
probably the most important lesson in
life
which is that your body
has intelligent design and it is
constantly sending you signals
and when something shrinks you depletes
you makes you feel like you're hiding
uh
that is a hugely important signal to pay
attention to and one of the simple
secrets in life
is
spend more time
with people
and doing experiences
that expand you or energize you and you
also said something important it has
nothing to do with whether or not
something is easy
or something is difficult and has
everything to do
with the kind of energy that you feel
when you're either in that experience or
you are with
those people that are meant for you and
so that's number one
uh in terms of just such an important
takeaway it took me a really [ __ ]
long time to to realize that that a lot
of why my life was so hard is because i
was spending time either with people
that depleted me
or in situations that depleted me or in
a job
that depleted me
and you know i can remember like it was
yesterday being
29 years old
and being here in boston and we had just
moved here and i could not get a job i
used i had been a public defender uh
working for legal aid in new york city
straight out of law school and then we
moved to boston for my husband's
for my husband to go to business school
and i was not a member of the bar so i
couldn't practice law in a courtroom so
the only job i could get was in a law
firm which is the exact
opposite
from walking into a courtroom and
representing people i was walking into a
high-rise and into an office
and then sitting at a desk all day
researching and writing i'm highly
dyslexic it's really hard for me to
focus my brain that way i would be
sitting on that commuter rail
with
almost like a visceral
hangover feeling um don't go don't go
like my whole body you know when you're
in a relationship or you're sleeping
with somebody or you're walking into a
job that doesn't feel right and too many
of us and especially women
we stay in these situations like it's
some kind of obligation to endure it or
to fix somebody else so it feels better
and you know i went into that job
every single day for more than a year
and then i got pregnant thank god
because while i was on maternity leave i
not only had massive postpartum
depression
but when i finally
got stabilized from the postpartum
depression i had this awakening that was
visceral i said to my husband i can't go
back to work i cannot do it the idea of
walking in there now that i've been
separated from it is making me
physically ill and then he said well no
problem we've just bought this house
uh we can't afford it unless you're
working so you gotta go make sixty
thousand dollars so now i had a problem
i had four weeks before i had to walk
back into that job and i had to find a
job that made sixty thousand dollars and
boy did i get to work and i think if you
frame
life change often particularly like
getting a job like a problem to solve
sometimes it makes it easier to figure
out how to solve it some motivation
to get by even though getting by for one
versus the other is totally different
i believe that we're stepping into an
age where we're gonna learn how to tap
into our body and like really be able to
sense truth and truths and lies and
indicators we're just we're just gonna
be more in touch physically with how our
outside reality makes us feel to be a
guide for us
i think that's what's going to be called
of us in this day and age where we can't
even we don't even know if we're
watching the news and it's true or false
we just we don't know anything what is
real what is not um
why is it what why is it that we don't
listen to those cues we don't we don't
listen to that little voice and sign
that has that quick little like you know
or like
i the answer's simple
you've been trained not to
how what what is it that trains us not
to
travel the aspects that we overlook in
our life that we do on a repetitive
basis that go
not the body not the intuition out here
you were trained as a child
that if you did
what your instincts told you to do
that you would get in trouble
or somebody would be mad at you like
that's how you parent children
through threats and intimidation i mean
come on i'm a parent like that's how i
just yeah
but but not really because you know as a
kid you want to keep the peace you want
to make sure that you're not uh you know
like it goes back to survival you are
hardwired to be part of a pack and the
pack that you're born into
for better or for worse is the one that
you're
wired
in your dna to stay connected to
and so
what happens
is you know we can talk about the range
of having a household that's safe
where you're just worried about your mom
being upset you're just worried about
dad not yelling and it's all
subconscious
you're just reading the cues
and so you know all you want to do is
dance and play and that's what your
intuition is telling you and to play
your records and to make and then so
like can you shut up it's been
you know and so you learn to stop
listening to what's in your heart and
soul and to
prioritize reading the cues
and then that only gets reinforced when
you go to school when it becomes
part of your uh
your your biological and your your
growth evolution
to form friendships and so your brain
has this moment where it goes from
accepting and loving you exactly as you
are to suddenly your brain turns into
the sorting hat from harry potter
and now
you look around and instead of seeing a
world that you want to explore
you see the groups you belong to and the
groups that you don't and your mind is
doing this as a way to protect you is
all evolutionary stuff
in terms of keeping you safe
and so instead of going to sit with the
sports kids or you know the kids that
look different than you or the kids that
are artsy you start to go oh well i
can't go there because i don't have nice
clothes and i can't go there because i
don't look like those kids and i can't
go there because and you start to
literally
talk yourself out of
following the pull of your heart i can't
possibly go out for the play because all
the kids will you know question my
sexuality if i'm a guy i can't possibly
quit the football team because my dad is
going to be pissed off at me
life taught you
to stop listening
to your own instincts
and part of the one of the greatest
opportunities
of your life as an adult
because once you're 18 you get to say
you have way more control than you think
you do
you get to say what job you want to go
and pursue you get to say
what you want to do for a living you get
to say who you're going to love and how
you're going to live your life
and
one of the greatest gifts of your
adulthood is coming back home to
yourself and learning how to remove the
crap that has been put on top of your
intuition the anxiety the people
pleasing the imposter syndrome the
penalties
the penalties
you know there are some like let's take
an example of somebody who grows up in a
wildly
uh conservative religious household
who is gay
and
being themselves means
that your family kicks you out yeah
your entire existence
is something you're hiding your identity
is what you're hiding because the
messaging
at you and the consequences as a child
were so severe and so you know people
experience this there's not a single
adult who has not
had life or abuse or trauma or some
situation
scream at you you can't be you
it's not or you gotta change if you want
me to like you you gotta change if you
want mom to be happy you gotta not be
totally yourself
if you want dad to love you
and then if you've had issues like
abandonment or you've had issues like
discrimination or abuse
the
experience of those things makes you as
a child question there well there's got
to be something wrong with me because if
there weren't something wrong with me my
father would still be here at the house
if there weren't something wrong with me
i wouldn't have been abused like this
this is sort of what
the child brain does it turns it back at
you and so this is
what every adult needs to repair
in order to tap back into
the wisdom that is inside you and to
hear
what your intuition and your soul is
trying to tell you
and the other reason why it's very hard
for people to hear
is because
you're so busy
you're so busy running from one thing to
the next you're kind of on autopilot
you're doing this thing you're not even
present and so it requires a slowing
down
and that's one of the greatest gifts of
the pandemic i think for a lot of people
that's why you're seeing the great
resignation and so many people quitting
their jobs that's why you're seeing
uh divorces skyrocket that's why you're
seeing
people
really
have a reckoning with themselves about
what's working what's not working
because the pandemic hit the pause
button and you didn't have anywhere that
you could go you couldn't run to target
or to get a
cup of coffee with a friend in order to
just be busy
you had to stay put very very well said
we could just stop there and that's
enough information for people to feast
on and just like go with right because
there's
there's there's two parts the first is
your is your
familial situation it's your it's your
upbringing it's your
childhood trauma and patterning
and then the other part is uh culture
and you know what your environment is
and how
everything is designed to distract you
um
and take you out of your relationship
with your inner self your inner child
whatever it is that you want to call it
um and and and place fear i think that's
been a big part of kind of this last
couple of years is there's just so much
fear propaganda
or fear porn as they would call it you
know it's just it's and it's and it's
crippling for for for so many people
um so let's start with the first one
which i think is the the one that uh
we have control over both of them but i
think it's almost the hardest one and
that's your own your own programming
from childhood i mean i'm fascinated
with psychology and fascinated with why
we are the way we are
and it's taken me into my late 30s to
really get a grasp on sort of the
patterns in my life showing up and the
um
you know childhood traumas that happen
with mom with dad and what we're what
we're looking for to resolve and then
how we act ourselves and it's all in the
it's all in the parents and
so
you know i think that's one of them i
think that's probably one of the most
important things that i have dealt with
personally is just taking a step forward
into those
those realities and maybe the most
important thing my therapist said to me
was that no one holds the keys it was
like i wanted to once i started
unpacking it was like i wanted to blame
mom or dad apologize and then everything
will be okay and it's like that doesn't
make it okay you have to
you have to come to terms with it and
once you do you actually don't need them
to do anything for you but the truth of
the matter is is that our childhood
plays an enormous role
on
what how we act in the world and what we
judge and what what we are what we end
up projecting against and what triggers
us i can give you an analogy so um
i think it's really important
when you
decide that you're going to
change your habits and change the
patterns of behavior
that make you feel stuck or that you
can't stand anymore that are the result
of surviving trauma you got to be
compassionate with yourself and patient
because a great analogy
for the patterns that you learned that
you're now stuck with right now it feels
like as an adult is this
you spent how many years
as a race car driver
how many years how many 27 years
imagine if when you retired i said okay
you're gonna play football now
and i expect you
to be the best
that's tall order i mean that's an
overwhelming prop proposal you know
yes
it's going to take years for you to
learn
a brand new sport
and it's going to take
small daily practice and studying
and being patient with yourself to build
new muscles and skills and the truth is
you might never
fully
build new muscles and skills it might
never come easily or naturally but over
time you could learn to be an excellent
football player
but what you have to have compassion for
is the fact that for the first 27 years
you were not playing football you were
driving a race car
and those are very different patterns
so if you're going to go from a
situation where you have a pattern of
withdrawing
into yourself or lying or snapping at
people or whatever your pattern is in
response to uncertainty
it's
literally the equivalent of teaching
yourself to go from being a professional
race car driver to a professional
football player
foreign just feels good totally
different skills totally different
neural pathways and so when you kind of
understand that that you can do it but
it's going to take time and i think one
of the things that was the most
eye-opening thing that i have ever
learned was this um and i only learned
this recently
one of the reasons why behavior change
is so frustrating and it's so hard and
you've got to use all these tools
in order to trick your brain and to plow
new neural pathways in and to form new
habits
the reason why it's so hard is because
when you and i are talking about
changing our behavior or we're talking
about trauma pattern or we're talking
about the [ __ ] that we do that we'd want
to change we're really frustrated by
we're using the conscious part of our
brain we're using the prefrontal cortex
talking about behavior change is easy to
do
the reason why it's so difficult is you
and i can sit here and talk about it and
we can make a plan for and we can say
okay the next time that that you're in a
situation where your husband gives you
that look and then you start to worry
that uh you know
going to happen you feel the rage come
up in your body like what used to drive
me bananas is my husband would ask me a
ton of questions
and in my opinion they're obvious stupid
questions and so you know i of course
feel like a royal [ __ ] now because
we've come to find out that my husband
has been struggling with long-term
depression and one of the reasons why he
has a brain you know why his brain is so
foggy is because of depression
and it didn't help that he was smoking a
ton of weed all the time too and so you
know i would literally get so frustrated
because he would we'd be talking about
something and he would be like
uh well i don't know what do you what do
you think like just asking questions and
i'm like you should know the answer to
that one
have you heard of google why are you
asking me what the weather is going to
be you know tomorrow in vermont [ __ ]
google like you're like and i'd go like
ah
and i hated that about myself
hated it and i would talk to my
therapist i can't snap at him i don't
want like i i i need to be more patient
you know this is what my mom did like
she would get frustrated with my father
and now i'm doing it with chris and i
don't want to be that person
oh my god i would talk about this topic
probably for years
and i would make a plan to become and
i'd make a plan to put myself in pause
and then the next day or two
i'd get back in my life and we'd be
standing there having a conversation
and he would ask me a question
that i think he should have googled or
should know the answer to and then the
rage would come
and it wasn't until i learned the fact
that i was talking about the behavior
that i wanted to change with this part
of my brain
but the rage and the impatience and the
kind of like ah the kind of like
emotional reactiveness
pattern is stored here
in the basal ganglia
that pattern operates
in my subconscious
and that pattern is not initiated by
thinking that pattern is initiated by
emotions that rise up in the body
and it's only when you realize that the
behavior change particularly when it
comes to generational patterns and
trauma patterns
that in order to
catch it
you've got to not only
figure out the pattern you want to
change but you've got to figure out the
situations and the emotions that you're
feeling in your body
that
correspond to the pattern
that you want to change
because when i start to feel my ankles
getting hot
i know that that feeling in my body that
emotion of frustration
that is the trigger
and the reason why i have this pattern
this is fascinating is that
you know a lot of these patterns you
learned
like zero to two
yeah i think they say zero to six it's
like last trimester to about six years
old is the
bulk of the subconscious programming
which is 95 percent of your operating
system yeah
yeah and they they they have this
there's this phenomenon in psychology
called ghosts
in the nursery
which mean and i'll give you an
explanation um
so let's say
they're we're looking at uh 18 month old
mel robbins an 18 month old mel robbins
is sitting on the kitchen floor
and i've got the tupperware drawer open
and 18 month old mel robbins is lost
because i'm following my soul and i am
playing with the tupperware and i got
this stuff all over and i've made a big
mess and i'm just like happy as a little
clam
and then all of a sudden around the
corner like my mom comes and she's
walking around the corner and doesn't
see me and slips and like ah and just
reacts
what happens in my nervous system
is that
her frustration
with the mess
and the blow up
and the fact that i have a
disruption in my nervous system because
i'm startled
i
literally
sear
her behavior
with my emotional reaction
so frustration gets encoded in me i
don't even remember it i'm 18 months old
frustration
is always
this emotional feeling in my body and
now i'm just
literally copying the behavior yeah i
saw in the adults
passenger at that point in time correct
correct and so
because emotions rise up before your
thoughts take hold yeah
it's super important to pay attention to
your body is it a is it a twitch in the
stomach is it a clench in the you know
my husband says that when he feels kind
of his pattern of withdrawing kick in he
first feels like his chest titan
that's what he feels that's that's how
he knows one of those patterns from his
past in his subconscious that he doesn't
want as an adult is about to spin
and so if he can catch it here he can
say oh here it goes i'm about to
withdraw five four three two one i'm not
gonna do that i'm gonna choose something
different and so that's been wildly
helpful and it allowed me to go oh i get
it this is why it's not that i'm a [ __ ]
it's that i'm talking about the behavior
i want to change with one part of my
brain but the behavior itself is
somewhere else so i gotta fight it
in the region that it's in and it's also
really important you can't just catch it
you can't just interrupt it you must
replace it with a new pattern of
behavior because patterns repeat
you have to reprogram yourself
a question i have too cause this is uh
something i use as an indicator um i'll
use my own personal example it's um
you know if somebody is uh to to reflect
on you when he's he should have looked
up something simple and obvious just
google it whatever for me it's like i
judge lazy people so i'm like god like
really just like you're complaining
about that you haven't done anything or
you you know you're just sitting around
don't you want to do something and so i
realized too that yes of course there's
part of my childhood programming the i
wasn't allowed to do those things and so
therefore in my adulthood i don't do
those things meaning like i'm not i
don't i can't be lazy it's hard for me
to be lazy i don't know how to be lazy
it's like programmed in me and so
another indicator that i use is like
what i judge i deny on some level and so
i bet that you're the kind of person
that would never ask a stupid question
you'd google it first you'd do your
homework you'd do your research and then
if you couldn't figure it out you'd you
know present the presented and be like i
did everything i couldn't find it do you
know you wouldn't just go hey you know
what's weather tomorrow you'd be like i
mean you would have looked right
probably yeah
yeah definitely you know it's
interesting it makes me wonder
um given that it was sort of like just
drilled into your head
work work work work work
do you find it really difficult
to
even
like relax on a vacation
um
i think that in the past my vacations
were like it took a couple days to kind
of get to the to down regulate enough to
enjoy it which is why i would never take
less than five day vacations because by
the time i came down for the three days
i was already thinking i only had two
left so like at least seven gave me like
a couple to come down i'm like oh man i
got so many days left and they have a
couple good days and then there's still
the ramp up of knowing you need to get
going again um i'm better now um
so but i i would say that you know it
took a long time to do something simple
like just sit on the couch and watch tv
i would always think i'd have to be
doing something maybe even just like is
it a fun show am i being entertaining am
i asking good questions is it like there
had to be a little added layer to it so
i'd say that watching tv and just
resting and letting that be enough and
be in silence especially if somebody's
there is like something that took a
little while for me to
to be able to do comfortably well one of
the things that i've uh learned recently
about myself
is that because i don't you i wouldn't
the lazy word caught my attention
and
what
i've unpacked for myself is that i
am always doing something
because like so many people
i got
the most positive attention when i was
achieving
and so i married
achievement
with being worthy of love
and i know that if i
i know that i never slowed down and i
was constantly on to the next thing
because if i wasn't up to something that
was worth talking about
it must have meant that i wasn't worth
loving either
and it was in the doing and the
achieving that i anchored my worth
and it's only again recently that i've
really been able to
see that and pull it apart
and realize that you know the things
that i do have to be separate
from
whether or not i view myself as worthy
or lovable or
likable
that as a person based on who i am and
just my existence alone you got to
anchor it there
and let the things that you're doing
just be additive
to
you enjoying your life how did you
figure it out
it was the high five habit honestly like
i like i didn't figure it out i was 52
years old and it was a like a
holy [ __ ] i cannot believe for how long
i have tortured myself i have
just drilled myself
um you know you asked at the very
beginning if you know what my thoughts
are on us needing seasons and
you know i live in a four season climate
i love the change of seasons and one of
the most important things
about uh winter
is that when you think about how what
winter is for it's a period where
everything falls off the trees and all
that stuff that dies and falls to the
ground becomes
what nourishes
and uh
feeds
the things that are going to grow
in the spring and without the winter and
without the freeze and without the dying
off of the growth from last year
you wouldn't have the new growth and so
i deeply believe not only
in seasons where you need to rest and
seasons where things need to die and
fall off and see seasons where things
need to you know be reborn or to grow
again anew but i think that you can
start a new one anytime you decide to
and that that's also a really amazing
aspect of kind of finally waking up and
realizing you're in control of a lot
more
than you realize that you are you can
choose what you think about it it's not
easy yeah the process is simple but it's
not easy because you're fighting against
patterns but you can make a decision to
change your life you can make a decision
to change
uh what you value you can make a
decision to change who you hang out with
you can make a decision to change what
you do for a living these are all things
within your control they don't come from
wishing about them yeah they're going to
come from work yeah it's kind of that
day one or one day kind of thing
and and i've thought about this because
i know you talk about this and and i
love the attitude of like just it just
make the decision
count to five five second rule just do
it right um which is
such a great practice
um but i i was thinking about that and
i'm also
i also do think that there's some meat
to the fact that
there's stuff that leads up to going ah
i can't take it anymore i'm making a
change if an epiphany something hits
hard enough you're over it like you just
hit a breaking point and something does
change in a moment it always changes in
a moment and it's up to you to get to
that moment
so what can we do to get to that moment
with routines practices disciplines
how do we get there because there's got
to be there's always something that
leads up to it
well um
one thing that i've learned in life
is that
your breakdowns are just going to keep
getting bigger
until you wake the [ __ ] up and get the
lesson that the universe is sending i
mean
period
uh it took me a long time to see
that i had a
very
uh
painful pattern of being drawn to really
big personality people who were really
fun and edgy and just like wow like a
shiny object
and then you know when you're having fun
with this kind of person and you're
laughing all the time and they're really
edgy and you start to realize oh my god
they're actually kind of mean to people
or they're they lie or they do this
now all of a sudden i get scared
because i don't know how to back away
and time and time and time and time like
i can go all the way back
to
uh
friends in elementary school to
uh a babysitter that i once hired to
business uh associates back in the day
to like just there they are there they
are there they are there they are there
they are and it wasn't until i had a
massive issue happened with one of them
super painful
that made me go holy [ __ ]
this is a pattern
this person has been showing up in your
life since you were nine years old
and you have not learned it and now
you have a very expensive and a very
messy and a very
awful situation to clean up with
somebody that you couldn't draw
boundaries with period because you were
so worried about upsetting anybody or
disappointing like your people pleasing
and so one thing to understand is
your life is the greatest school you're
ever gonna attend and it's always
sending you messages
preach and
i hope you're not as stubborn as i am
because it took me 41 years
to
see the lesson
about
toxic behavior that i was attracted to
and toxic behavior that i engaged in in
my own people-pleasing
and inability to draw a line and like
distance myself or end relationships
that really didn't work
and i know they don't work because i get
that feeling in my stomach and then i
see myself twisting myself in knots so
as to not upset somebody who's basically
crazy
and i'm now like turning all around to
not upset the person that is you know
i'm afraid of their reaction
because they're not regulated in terms
of their emotions and so i it took me a
long time and so i want every i want you
to understand if you're listening to
this that if you're in a frustrating
situation
i want you to ask yourself number one
when in my life have i felt like this
before
and who has made me feel like this what
situations have made me feel like this
and start listing them and when you see
one you'll see another and then another
and then another and then there's that
boss and then there's a situation
and then
you'll ask yourself
what is it that i'm doing
that is having me
show up in this situation again and so i
identified kind of the the personality
pattern that i was drawn to fun
unpredictable like oh your life of the
party like kind of like just whew this
feels fun and this feels on edge because
i can't predict
what's gonna happen because this
person's so entertaining only to realize
holy [ __ ] the same thing that drew me in
is what's scaring me now and turning me
into a massive people pleaser that makes
me go crazy and so
i
if you can identify that
then you ask yourself
what is the lesson that life is trying
to teach me
this person is being sent into my life
to teach me a lesson
and for me the lesson again back to your
original question why can't we listen to
our instincts
how many of us have started dating or
sleeping with somebody
that we knew
we knew
we knew we shouldn't have been dating or
sleeping with
and then we keep going back
even though we knew that this is not a
person that we should be with
and we like
turn into somebody else reckoning with
our and this person is being sent into
your life for a reason because you have
a pattern that you need to break
and so when you can identify those three
things kind of when in my life have i
felt this way before what are the
circumstances or people i've been around
what am i doing that i can see
contributes to me getting into these
situations
and what is this trying to teach me
and when you can look at it that way
that's how you unpack awful situations
or confronting situations and you look
for the lesson in them
and if you don't figure out the freaking
lessons you're meant to learn in this
lifetime
your you will just keep i'm embarrassing
them
that's it that is it
and so you know that's one thing that i
have learned recently
um and then the other thing that i have
learned
and you know it's what i you wrote about
in the high five habit is this notion
that
you know there's only one person that
you spend your whole life with and it's
yourself
and i had this epiphany
uh in april of 2020 when i walked into
the bathroom one morning
and you know there's a lot of [ __ ] going
on in my life and it doesn't even matter
what the details were because i think
everybody's had that experience where
you're in a season of your life
that's just overwhelming
and you don't
feel
capable or
like you have
one shred of energy left to face this
[ __ ]
and
i remember standing there in the
bathroom and i had this epiphany one
morning
where i realized oh my god there are
always two human beings in the bathroom
every morning
there's you and there's a human being in
the mirror
that's not your reflection
if you allow yourself to really look
past the body in the mirror and through
the eyes you will see
you will see a human you'll see your
soul
and that woman that's staring back at
you in the mirror she is trying
she is so beaten down by you she is so
sick of your criticism
she
needs you to wake up and start
supporting her
and to start being kinder to her
she's doing her best
and kind of this epiphany that i
was relentless
in my criticism of myself
even just 18 months ago
even having
turned my life around
built this business got our family out
of the million dollars in debt got the
liens off the house which you know they
were there six years ago the leans
from the million dollars in debt that my
husband and i were in because of the
restaurant business
and
despite the fact that i've impacted
millions of people's lives despite the
fact that i have three kids that are
okay you know they're healthy they you
know are facing their stuff they're
doing their thing they're going to
school despite the fact that i've i've
been you know married for 25 years and
we still work on it ever like despite
the fact that i got a roofer i look in
the mirror and i see
a woman
that i hated
that wasn't enough that that was doing
everything wrong i was relentlessly
focused
on what wasn't working
instead of all of the things
that were going right
and when i had this epiphany that oh my
god like there's this poor lady in the
mirror every morning
who just wants me to see her and wants
me to start being kinder to her and
needs my support my whole life switched
like i had life inverted
in so many ways because you know i was
kind of it sounds like you like i was
brought up i i wasn't in an abusive
household at all i was in like your
normal
kind of like you know
happy household whatever
um
my parents have their own [ __ ] from
their childhoods and
everybody does and so
you know i though kind of had that
that sense of okay
tough love man push yourself you gotta
muscle through it
and i think
between
the constant criticizing that you do of
yourself to try to fit in
and
the fact that that then gets
reinforced by experiences in your life
i just adopted a habit that everybody
has
rejecting myself
not accepting myself
constantly badgering myself for the
things that weren't going right instead
of the million things that are
yeah and when i reverse this
and started to
add in habits
around
empowering myself cheering for myself
forgiving myself
giving myself some grace being a little
kinder to myself
focusing on what's working instead of
harping on what's not
it is bananas how much
my experience of life changed good job
by the way
thank you
i'm it's hard to get to that point where
we
actually acknowledge our inner monologue
as being important
and even notice it instead of being on
the wheel of the same [ __ ] we say to
ourselves in our head every day when we
are in the workplace or with our partner
or looking in the mirror and we say the
same [ __ ] every day right i do
and
we're harder on ourselves it's like i
love
i love you know there's i think maybe it
was untethered soul but talking about
the way that you talk to yourself like
you would never be friends with your
inner monologue never like who would
ever be friends with the stuff that we
say to ourselves in our head
so what i hear a lot of is i hear
accountability
in this practice of saying
i'm going to treat
myself my inner child like to me it was
you know when i hear that i don't know
what you call it but if it were me look
in the mirror saying that's my inner
child going i [ __ ] love you like
you're beautiful you're amazing
why are you so hard on me like yourself
why why um because you were trained to
be hard on yourself that's the answer
like i like i literally
the thing that's so profound about this
for me
is that
when you realize this is just a pattern
of thinking
that your mom has with herself your dad
has with himself
every human being is trained to beat
themselves up
and you can
make a decision to stop doing it
and it is a conscious decision
that you have to intentionally make and
then manage all
day long and what's amazing though about
your brain
is because your brain is designed to
learn patterns
the switch is very quick
it's easier in my opinion to change the
default patterns in your brain than to
kind of
smooth out the trauma that is remembered
in your nervous system oh sure seeing it
for the first time takes forever
changing is the quickest part that's why
people are in the [ __ ] i'm like you're
actually a lot further than you think
yeah totally and so
the cool thing is that when you get to
work on your thinking patterns it
happens super
it can happen super fast in fact that's
why i'm so excited about
the idea and the research behind
adding a high five
in the mirror every morning to your
morning routine and the reason why it is
such a powerful habit when it comes to
your inner monologue is because you're
unlocking neural association and
programming that is already
in your brain in your nervous system in
your chemistry and you're now going to
aim it back at yourself
and you're going to aim it back at
yourself as a way to
delete the critic in your head and to
replace it with what you need which is
an encouraging voice
and by simply physically raising your
hand don't even say anything just
physically raise your hand and high-five
the woman you see in the mirror every
morning after you brush your teeth what
happens is all the positive programming
that's triggered by the physical hand
gesture of high fiving
it literally
gets triggered right here in your
subconscious
so the funny thing is is that you can be
standing there you're using your
prefrontal cortex you're like okay
i'm gonna do this stupid high five thing
as you go to raise your hand you think
danica and mal are the dumbest things i
cannot believe i'm doing this [ __ ]
and then as you get close to the mirror
something weird happens your mind goes
silent
because your brain is triggered by the
high five gesture and pulls programming
from your subconscious this is positive
programming your subconscious you've
never high-fived somebody and thought i
hate you i hope you lose today's a
terrible day you've only high five
people when you're like i see you i love
you keep going you got this we can win i
believe in you
it's celebratory yeah i respect you so
when you do it to yourself
the
subconscious programming overrides the
critic it's insane you will likely laugh
the first time you do it because your
brain then gives you a drip of dopamine
the other thing that you will feel is
you'll feel a slight little kind of like
oh i got okay okay this is weird but
that sort of little energy boost comes
because your nervous system
is encoded with celebratory energy when
your team scores you throw your hands in
the air when you're uh yell surprised at
a birthday party hands in the ear when
you cross the finish line hands in the
air when you wave hello hands in the air
when you high-five somebody hands in the
air and so when you high-five yourself
positive subconscious programming
drip of dopamine boosts your mood and
the celebratory energy in your nervous
system gives you a little jolt and
that's not all
your brain is watching
and your brain
sees you
treating yourself
like a person
who
cares about you
that leverages behavioral activation
therapy because you are now acting like
somebody
who cares about themselves
and we've done this thing called the
high five challenge where
i think it's been live for about
48 days we've had 145 000 people take it
it's a five day online
experience where i coach you every day
in a video there's 145 000 people in it
from 91 countries we have the data
because it's hosted on an app it's a
hundred percent free
and people are joining it every single
day and
we have measured the results not a
single person that's taken it just said
this hasn't worked not a single one
unreal we are getting uh
people talking about how it's spreading
through aaa meetings because there's so
much shame
and there's such a sense of failure when
there's things in your life that you
regret and so you know one of the
reasons why it's so powerful as a tool
for forgiveness is so many people
50 of men and women
don't or can't look at themselves in the
mirror because they don't like the
person that they are or they are
disgusted with where they are in life 91
of people don't like how they look and
so when they look in the mirror they
pick apart or fixate on what they don't
like these are habits of self-rejection
it's like giving yourself the middle
finger every time it's like the high
five is the opposite of what we normally
do which is basically look in the mirror
and go like this we just get that right
oh your hair is not that you know and
you're kind of a little fat here and
you're like you're kind of looking a
little old there and with gray hair like
or you know just you're a failure you do
don't do anything you don't deserve to
get ready and even try today no one's
going to care you don't care it's a
giant giant middle finger to yourself
most days every day opposite of it yeah
that's the opposite of it
what i'm fascinated by also is i is the
physical touch aspect
how does that play into things
well um there's a tremendous amount of
research about the power of a high five
when somebody else gives you one and
there and it's because there's a
transfer of energy from one person to
the other
and what they know based on research
because there's two studies that people
tend to fixate on
once they read the book and the first
one is the study that they did with mba
teams where researchers at the
university of berkeley looked at uh
championship nba teams and they wondered
were there preseason habits that this
team had that the losers didn't have and
it turns out there were it was a
surprising one and what it was was high
fives fist bumps and pats on the back
teams that win at the end of the season
have the most high fives fist bumps and
pats on the back at the beginning of the
season why well because these aren't
just meaningless gestures
these gestures create trust and
partnership
they create forward momentum
and so teams that were doing that
frequent and early on built trust and
partnership and forward momentum that
carried them through to win the season
now the wall street journal editors read
about the study and we're like there's
no way this is true and then wrote a
huge article after watching all the
tapes and going actually this is true
um and so
when you do that with yourself you're
creating trust and partnership
with yourself and forward momentum
sending you into the game of life every
day the other study that people love is
the one with um students in a classroom
and so researchers wanted to know if you
gave students a really challenging
problem to work through what's the best
way to motivate them to work harder work
longer kind of push through the really
challenging aspect of this
and so they tested three different um
types of encouragement they divided
these kids up into three groups the
first group the researchers would walk
over
and simply
uh
tell them something nice like a
compliment and this is kind of why words
of affirmation don't really work you
know oh you're really smart oh you're
doing a great job oh you know i can see
you're like whatever the second
group the researchers walked up and
complimented the kids on their effort oh
i see you're trying really hard oh i see
you really working you know the growth
versus a fixed mindset the third
group this is where this gets
interesting
the researchers
walked up and didn't say a word
they just gave the kid as they're
struggling through this challenge a high
five those kids that got a high five
worked like outworked
like
10x the other groups
they worked longer they worked
for better result and here's the most
important part
they felt
best about themselves compared to the
other groups why
well the reason why
is again
because it's not just a gesture that's
meaningless what the high five
communicated is
i see you so a high five when somebody's
struggling is i see you're struggling
and i'm here to encourage you
it says i hear you i hear that you're
struggling i'm here to encourage you
and
it says
i believe in you
which is exactly what we all need to
hear this is why by the way
we are incessant people pleasers it's
because we
literally are looking for other people
to see us to tell us that they hear us
and to tell us that they love us like us
and believe in us and i'm here to tell
you that the best way to get that need
that that is so important fulfilled is
to make it a habit to fill that need for
yourself every single morning by
high-fiving yourself in the mirror it
reminds me of kind of something we were
talking about earlier which is just you
know what am i trying to get from
someone
and i was like for me i was trying my my
whole dilemma was in relationship and i
wanted to be chosen
and i realized in that wanter need that
my lesson was i was supposed to be
giving it to myself
i was supposed to be choosing
myself which i didn't really know how to
do that usually requires you to leave
somebody you're with yeah oh well i mean
because the reality means that that
probably the situation you're in is is
trying is a pattern
so we're trying to
you know like in my experience you know
i'm trying to correct the dad wound
right i'm trying to occur i'm thinking
if i can correct the original wound
where i wasn't enough and i was pushed
really hard and hard on me and
emotionally disconnected if i can
correct it with someone
then it's oh everything's okay but it
will never happen these are just
patterns to show you something that
you're supposed to look within yourself
for
are there like big aha moments for you
um that you can think of where it was
like man that was it that's the
that's where i was supposed to be doing
the exact thing i wanted from somebody
because i think to myself like even with
a high five it's like a high five
yourself it's like you could also high
five other people too like you know what
i mean when you're already doing that
you treat yourself as the way you treat
other people
you treat everybody else way better than
you treat yourself so the issue is not
high-fiving everybody else the issue
is being able to look yourself in the
mirror
and see a human being that's worthy of
it
and if you struggle with shame
or regret
or your criticism is relentless
high-fiving yourself is going to feel
weird because when you look in the
mirror you see somebody who doesn't
deserve that you see
somebody who's made mistakes you see the
failure you see the things you regret
and one of the reasons why high-fiving
myself in the mirror and adding it as a
habit that i start every single day with
i send myself into the game of life
with that high five
one of the reasons why it has been so
transformative
is because it is a tool
that
teaches me how
how
to heal
all the things that i need to heal it is
a tool that teaches me how to like
myself as i am
even if i didn't go to the gym
even if i drank a bottle of wine last
night
and i'm hungover and i said i wouldn't
even if i snapped at my kids even if i
didn't get through the to-do list even
if i still haven't reached my goals i
still look in the mirror
and i see a person i like
i see a person i'm encouraging i see a
person who deserves that kind of support
and then i use the tool of the high five
habit to give myself that support
and that has changed everything because
when you like yourself
you don't
need to seek it from somebody else
like other people liking you is a bonus
if other people don't like you it might
sting a little bit but it doesn't change
the fact that you like yourself
and the reason why you can be sure that
you like yourself is because your brain
sees you
treating yourself every morning with
that high five in the mirror like a
person who likes themselves treats
themselves
same thing with respect
the reason why people have tremendous
difficulty with boundaries is because
they don't respect themselves
they disrespect themselves all day long
so how on earth are they going to find
the strength to have boundaries exactly
it begins with how you treat yourself in
the mirror every morning and then it
builds out from there if you treat
yourself with respect
you will not allow somebody else to
disrespect you
but we allow other people to disrespect
us because we treat ourselves with
disrespect yeah
you build it from the inside out
and so this has been the single greatest
lesson of my life
seriously
that being kind to yourself
being accepting and supportive of
yourself is the superpower is the source
of motivation is the source of
confidence
and what i love about it is it's a tool
it costs nothing
it works for everybody
uh there's tremendous science
and um it's free i think i'd like to
maybe wrap up by explaining boundaries
if somebody would have told me back in
the day like you're codependent i'd be
like no i'm not super strong i'm
independent i got it together i make my
own money i buy my own houses
i would have never said i'm codependents
i didn't get what that meant but
learning more it's like oh yeah maybe i
was
a big reason is that i didn't i didn't
even know what a boundary was
so could you explain
how people could learn how to create
boundaries and what they are
yeah
so um i like to use an example of an
electric fence
so you know when we've got an australian
shepherd named yolo
and we live across the street from this
farm outside of boston and there's three
dogs that are up across the street and
when yolo was a puppy oh my god he like
had the sonic hearing this dog could
hear when the door across the the street
and we're talking like at least a
quarter of a mile would crack open
because he would bolt at our screen door
plow it open run straight across the
yard jump over the stone wall right
across the street which is on a blind
corner and then right up the driveway to
the farm to go play with the dogs and so
we're like we got to get an electric
fence now when they install an electric
fence they put in these little white
perimeter flags and here's what's
interesting about the white flags you
want to think about white flags on an
electric fence as a boundary
first of all
nobody knows it's there if there aren't
the flags
and if you have a boundary it's your
responsibility to plant the white flags
so that you know where the boundary is
and so that the people in your life know
where the boundary is because what i've
noticed about the fence because you know
a lot of people then take the flags away
is that we didn't remove all of them
because i noticed our dog being an
australian shepherd loves to whoa
like he doesn't fight or hurt people but
he loves to charge at people to announce
their arrival and if people were riding
a horse down the street or walking down
the street and our dog went running
without the the the
flags they'd have a panic attack but
when you see
the flags
you know
the point at which you're safe
and they're safe
and ironically that boundary
that fence it's actually not for the
people
on the road
it's to keep yolo
okay
your boundaries keep you okay and you
safe and
your job is to figure out where to put
those little flags so other people see
them and there's there's
there's boundaries around stuff
there's boundaries around time
there's boundaries around topics
and there's boundaries around people
and so
a boundary around stuff is one that i'm
seeing expressed right now because both
of our daughters are home one of whom
has graduated from college and the other
who is a junior in college and one of
our daughters loves to borrow the other
daughter's stuff
and they are different sizes so it makes
our one daughter bananas because she
can't borrow as many things and so
she has expressed she's planted her
white flag and the white flag is this
you can only borrow my stuff
if you ask and i give you permission
that's a boundary
now if
her sister crosses it
she needs to enforce the boundary
you can no longer borrow my things
and if her sister crosses it again she
has to turn the voltage up on the fence
and put a lock on her door
time um
time boundaries are literally no i'm not
available
to help you paint your house on saturday
i am available for one hour
on thursday morning if you need help
that's a time boundary
topic boundaries
my weight
is not up for discussion
i will come to
uh christmas dinner but
not if we're talking politics
same thing with boundaries with people
i'm not coming if uncle bob is there
i didn't think of it from so many
different aspects but i can see how
thinking of them is important
now would you stress that
it's important to the flags are those
verbal flags
because i think myself if i were to if i
were to establish a boundary verbally
let's say with a partner i feel like
that's like relationships always bring
up the most crap right so yeah
you know the thought that you'd have is
like well they're they might leave
right like i don't want to scare them
off or leave but really the truth is is
that you're just saying
subconsciously i'd be thinking to myself
well that just means that uh like
subconsciously i think i'm not really
worth it like i'm not really worthy and
i'm not good enough
so remember these protect you so when
you express a boundary with a partner
what you're doing is you are
empowering yourself
to act like an adult in a relationship
yeah instead of having there be land
mines all over the place emotionally
where you get triggered and withdraw
right so i'll give you an example
so um
my husband recently came to me and
expressed what you would call a boundary
we have we live in an old farmhouse and
the garage is um like at the lower level
so you kind of pull in you can park up
top or you can pull around underneath to
the garage and
whenever we get packages you obviously
have boxes that arrive to the house
you have to carry them downstairs after
you unpack the boxes from amazon or
wherever in order to get them into the
recycling bins
well i have a habit
of stacking up the boxes empty boxes
like a giant tank like tango or whatever
game it is right at the top of the door
to the stairway to the basement
and for years i've done this and my
husband has never said anything
what he's done is he gets passive
aggressive
where there'll be 11 boxes there and
then he's like ripping the tape off and
like like angrily like slapping the
things down and i'm like why are you on
that you know like or like throw the
things down the stairs and everything or
like pick them up in a huff and finally
he said to me
would you
please
take the boxes downstairs to the garage
do not gather them at the top and i said
why i said i'm gathering there so i
don't have to make 15 trips and i know
you want him flat i don't have time and
so i'm putting my and he's like no i
need you to hear me
i need you to stop doing it it's a major
boundary for me and then he explained
why which was super helpful yeah when i
see that tower
of cardboard boxes
it makes me feel like you think i'm the
maid
it makes me think you're stacking that
there
for me to take care of
and
it makes me
feel
like you don't care about me
and when you explain it that way i'm
like oh my god no prob there will never
be another box here and there hasn't
been because i understand
yeah
what he's working on and why this is
important and he incorporated feelings
he actually knows how he feels and he's
communicating it and communication is
the most important thing whether we're
talking about a boundary
the communication we have with ourselves
in the mirror
or just how he feels when certain things
are done that make him feel less than
triggered and it's the communication
that's so important but without the
self-awareness
you can't even get to the communication
so again it comes back to you yeah
always
wow
look i'm so excited to have this
conversation so many people including
myself there's so much to learn i'm
going to start high-fiving myself in the
mirror and i guarantee you i'm going to
probably feel a little silly i'm like
okay do i put a fingerprint on the
mirror or not and it's up to you you
know i'm going to do it every day put
the fingerprint on the mirror i'm
totally up for the reprogramming of
looking myself and going don't be
shocked let me know in five days what
happens
wow thanks mel you're incredible thank
you for this conversation thank you and
all the good you do i mean you're truly
impressive i just love listening to
you're so clear and articulate and
to the point and uh you help millions of
people
well i was really unhappy and screwed up
and suffering for a really long time and
it took me
many many decades of suffering
to
have these simple epiphanies
and i think that's why i sound so clear
and articulate because
your life and problems can seem
overwhelming and we tend to make the
mistake of thinking that that means the
solution is and it's actually the
opposite
the larger the issue the bigger the
struggle the smaller
the solution
that starts to change everything
well said
thank you thank you thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button